[Music]
all right joining me now is monica de la
cruz republican candidate for texas's
15th congressional district monica now
hardworking americans are really
concerned and worried
um and the democrats though have decided
to target a lot of these hard-working
people now recall that controversy
stoked by the media
about border agents who are supposedly
whipping migrants on horseback well they
were cleared of criminal conduct monica
but now the dhs
we understand still wants to punish them
so tonight what can you say about
hispanic voters in your district and
what they are saying about this issue of
border security and these media
lies look hispanic voters are seen
through the garbage that the democrats
are putting out
hispanic voters with their votes are
showing that they stand with border
patrol they stand with custom agents we
believe as hispanics in law and order
and what the biden administration is
doing to our law enforcement officers
and our brave men and women on the
border is just disgusting and hispanics
are going to show that feeling of
disgust with the democrat party in
november i was talking to my kids uh
tonight and before i came to the studio
and i said that hispanic americans are
going to save the country i really
believe that the new immigrant base in
this country they didn't come here
because they wanted a lower standard of
living and
to be demonized they came here for a
better life
and instead they're being handed this
they've warmed over socialism it's just
not going to work you're a former
democrat
that's exactly right i am a former
democrat who walked away from the
democrat party because a democrat party
is far removed from the values that are
important to hispanics those values
include their faith it includes their
family and it includes love of country
my great-grandparents and my
grandparents had the american dream and
that's why they came here and for
democrats to say that dream no longer
exists is ridiculous and hispanics are
here because they believe the dream
exists and they want to be part of it
what do you say to the establishment
republicans who still believe that the
only way to really solidify hispanic
support is to push kind of a massive
amnesty for people who are coming across
the border do you buy that
look hispanics very simply want the
opportunity to work they're hard workers
who love their family who love the
american dream and who want law and
order in their communities your viewers
tonight can find out more about myself
and my district at monica for congress
dot u s and learn more about what the
movement
is down here in the rio grande valley
and we're leading
this effort nationwide and it's starting
right here in my district well monica
the numbers these poll numbers for uh
democrats on issues like border
enforcement and the economy they are i
mean i've never i don't think i've ever
seen
numbers this bad but we're going to be
watching your district very closely in
all of south texas which looks like it's
going to be a massive red wave thank you
so much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else